"Не згадуй про війну"
Це відома фраза з британського комедійного серіалу Fawlty Towers.
Її сенс полягає в тому, що, зустрівши німця, перше, що спадає на думку, - Друга світова війна.
Проте, мовляв, згадувати про це в жодному разі не слід.
Уявіть моє здивування, коли я, перемикаючи канали під час однієї з перших мандрівок до Німеччини, побачила війну скрізь!
Телепрограму щодня приправляють довгими серйозними документалками про Гітлера та фільмами про Другу світову.
Саме так я вперше зрозуміла, що Німеччина взагалі не ігнорує своє темне минуле.
Однак так було не завжди. Багато років після війни тема націонал-соціалізму залишалася табу в родинах.
Батькам і дідам не ставили незручні запитання про їхню роль у минулому.
Деякі фільми й книжки на кшталт "Бляшаного барабана" Ґюнтера Ґрасса почали досліджувати цю тему.
Проте лише хвиля антисемітського вандалізму 1959-60 років пробудила людей.
Освіта отримала нове спрямування. Коли німці мого покоління були в школі,
Голокост та націонал-соціалізм вже давно були невід'ємною складовою навчального плану.
Багато людей почали цікавитися роллю власних рідних у тих подіях.
Звісно, важко чи навіть неможливо порівнювати жахи Голокосту з будь-чим іншим.
Але особисто я дуже мало чула про темні розділи історії моєї країни на уроках чи в публічних дискусіях.
Тож, як сторонню спостерігачку мене вражає, як у Німеччині знову й знову
відкрито тематизують цю болісну сторінку історії.
Важливою мотивацією є страх, що історія може повторитися.
Кілька років тому правопопулістська партія була обрана до Бундестагу,
а країну сколихнула низка правоекстремістських вбивств.
Постійна присутність поліції перед багатьма німецькими синагогами
нагадує про те, що тінь антисемітизму все ще лишається.
Тож, наскільки релевантною історія Німеччини є сьогодні?
І скільки відповідальності все ще несуть німці?
Ми, німці, не можемо пишатися своєю історією.
Тільки тому, що минуло так багато часу і нині ніхто особисто не винен,
не можна просто сказати: це не ми.
Ми нічого не можемо проти цього вдіяти, наші діти теж, наші онуки. Колись варто поставити крапку.
Через 70-80 років по тому казати, що ми винні, як на мене, занадто.
Проте я гадаю, що ми несемо відповідальність, ми мусимо запобігти тому, щоб таке повторилося.
Чи достатньо, замало чи забагато про це говорять у Німеччині?
Неможливо говорити про це забагато.
Іноді мені здається, що це вже занадто - знову й знову.
Гадаю, у Німеччині ця тема все ще табуйована.
Думаю, говорять багато. Але дедалі менше уваги, щоб оцінити сказане.
Коли ти приходив зі школи додому і чогось довідався, звісно, задавав питання і батькам чи дідусеві з бабусею.
Батьки, які жили ще в ті часи, хотіли певною мірою дистанціюватися, навіть якщо нічого спільного з цим не мали.
Що мене завжди дивує, так це те, що це покоління нібито нічого не знало про те, що тоді відбувалося.
Чи боїтеся ви іноді, що подібне може статися знову?
Так, цілком.
Це може статися будь-коли. Ми не стали розумнішими, ніж люди тоді.
Ні, не боюся. Ми в Європі багато чого навчилися. Перша і Друга світові війни - не думаю, що таке може повторитися.
Людство стало розсудливішим.
Працюючи над Meet the Germans, я усвідомила, що наслідки нацистської ери відчутні скрізь у Німеччині.
Деякі речі очевидні - наприклад, чоловіків з ім'ям Адольф у наші дні у ФРН не особливо зустрінеш.
Однак війна і нацисти виринали, коли я готувала серії про туризм, фільми, моду - здавалося б, зовсім недотичні теми.
Це мало безперечний вплив на національну гордість. У Німеччині рідко можна побачити стяг, що розвівається з вікна
- хіба що саме проходить першість світу з футболу.
І явної гордості збройними силами теж не спостерігається.
Насправді німецьке військо, схоже, частіше висміюють, ніж вітають.
Не можна сказати, що більшість німців не пишаються своєю країною. Пишаються.
Але їхній патріотизм зазвичай тихий і прагматичний, а не гучний чи емоційний.
Німці здебільшого налаштовані проєвропейськи.
Однією з цілей створення ЄС врешті-решт було забезпечення миру в Європі.
Деякі нагадування про війну можна побачити, просто гуляючи на вулиці. Візьмімо оцю будівлю!
Будинок мистецтва в Мюнхені - відомий приклад нацистської архітектури.
Що ж з таким робити? Чи достатньо переінакшити щось заплямоване, та й усе? Чи необхідно знищити будівлю?
Після багаторічної дискусії про будівлі на кшталт цієї одностайного рішення так і немає.
А як щодо меморіалів жертвам нацистів?
Їх можна знайти по всій Німеччині.
Часто організовані та профінансовані місцевими громадами.
Лише у 2005 році уряд ФРН відкрив перший офіційний меморіал закатовним євреям Європи.
Зворушливий меморіал Голокосту в центрі Берліна став однією з найвідвідуваніших принад міста.
Ще за три роки з'явився перший державний меморіал, присвячений гомосексуальним жертвам.
А 2012 року - меморіал убитим рома і синті.
Скромним, але вражаючим вираженням поминальної культури тут є так звані "Stolpersteine" - "камені спотикання".
Ці маленькі мідні квадрати, наяких вигравірувані імена жертв нацистського режиму,
встановлюють на тротуарах за останньою відомою адресою
Проєкт у 1990-их ініціював німецький митець Ґунтер Демніґ. Нині по всій Німеччині та за її межами встановлено 75 тисяч таких каменів.
Однак і тут не обійшлося без суперечки. Місто Мюнхен офіційно заборонило встановлювати такі камені
на громадських ділянках після того, як деякі люди, включно з відомим очільником єврейської громади,
заявили, що це неповага - вшановувати жертв чимось, по чому можуть ходити люди.
Натомість місто віддало перевагу отаким настінним табличкам.
Однак повернімося до того, з чого почали - комедії.
Гітлера та нацистів не раз висміювали у сатирі. Британська зірка німого кіно Чарлі Чаплін
поклав початок фільмом "Великий диктатор" ще 1940 року.
У 2019 році новозеландський режисер Тайка Вайтіті поглузував з фюрера у фільмі "Кролик Джоджо".
А як з цим у Німеччині?
Ви, приміром, могли б собі уявити, що напишете книгу, в якій Гітлер прокидається в сучасному Берліні?
Як би він реагував на Анґелу Меркель та багатокультурність?
Як би він здобував славу, але цього разу як телезірка?
Саме це, власне, зробив німецький автор Тімур Вермеш. Його книга "Він знову тут" 2012 року
очолила список бестселерів у Німеччині, а згодом була екранізована.
Мені просто здалася величезною ця суперечність. Коли читаєш "Майн кампф" загалом, з одного боку, маємо типа,
який вважає себе генієм, а з іншого -  від першої сторінки читання проглядає хтось, хто жебрає про визнання.
І саме такі суперечності дають дуже гарне підґрунтя для гумору.
Люди не казали, що ви перейшли межу?
Так, але вони не могли обґрунтувати, що саме не можна було робити. Нерідко йдеться лише про завчене табу,
яке ні на чому не ґрунтується. Реакції читачів були дуже різні.
Одні вважали дивним, як можна так довго витримати у голові Гітлера, адже голова змін не зазнала.
Це Гітлер в оригіналі. Інші ж казали: "Супер, як він критикує Меркель!
Він каже те, що давно пора сказати!" Вони, вочевидь, дуже швидко забули, хто саме це промовляє…
Читач наодинці з книгою. Він може сказати, що це занадто. Так не піде! Далі краще не читати.
Але він не робить цього. Адже це таки кумедно.
Тепер час розповідати вам. Що ви думаєте про те, як Німеччина опрацьовує своє минуле? Пишіть у коментарях!